meanwhile there has been more violence
between the Israeli Army and Hezbollah
along the Lebanon border Israel says its
Iron Dome defense system has intercepted
a number of rockets near the border in
Upper Galilee and Hezbollah says it
fired nearly 50 Rockets that's the most
intense shelling by the group since the
war in Gaza began no casualties have
been reported lahod reports from the in
southern
Lebanon there is no doubt the conflict
along the border is escalating another
day of escalating violence Israel radio
calling this the largest shelling since
the start of the war since Hezbollah the
Lebanese armed group joined the battle
against Israel to help relieve its Ally
Hamas in Gaza so 48 Rockets according to
Hezbollah it is claiming responsibility
for targeting what it says is a military
barracks in safad it wasn't the only
attack there were nine other Hezbollah
military operations along the border
since the early early hours of the
morning you can hear the constant sound
of shelling behind me this seems to be a
retaliation if you like for Israel's air
strike that killed six Hezbollah
fighters in a house in the southern
border Village of B Yun yesterday no
doubt a a blow for Hezbollah the group
has already lost 86 men since the start
of the War the group has told El jazer
that uh it will be ready to hold fire it
will be comply with the truce between
the Israeli Army and Hamas if Israel
abides by that truce but the biggest
question that is being asked in Lebanon
is indeed after that truce even if guns
fall silent for a few days what will be
next the Iranian foreign minister was in
Beirut and he issued yet another warning
he said that the war could expand if
that ceasefire does not continue so
strong words from the Iranian foreign
minister a network of groups across the
region allied with Iran have been trying
to pressure both Israel and US forces uh
but so far what we have been seeing is
that Israel the Israeli Army has been
very much on the offensive if you like
whether in Lebanon or in Syria yesterday
targeting Damascus uh the Syrian Capital
so many really are concerned on what
comes next